[Music]
so what's the number one sign that a
relationship is getting serious you get
to meet the family check that box off
for Jennifer Lopez and a rod and that is
not the only romance milestone they hit
this weekend
[Applause]
it was take your girlfriend to work day
for JLo and a-rod a couple of a few
weeks at Cosi side-by-side on the
backseat of a cop car heading in to
watch a Yankees spring training game
this weekend
JLo had on almost the same look she wore
when they first met tan sweater white
tank and a baseball cap hey rod well he
did some interviews for his new gig as a
fox sports analyst well things are
moving fast for j-rod JLo is meeting his
family on Friday hayride sister Susie
dune and posted two pictures she hashtag
this one meets Kunis which is Spanish
slang for sister-in-law bye before you
jump to any conclusions it's just a sign
that Susie has welcomed JLo to the
family she used to call me on my cell
phone
but does JLo have a bitter ex you did a
song together and I will see if it's on
his next album but he just asked me to
do a song with him and that's what we've
been doing well Drake dropped a playlist
for his new album or life and somebody
is missing no duet but on the opening
track free smoke the rapper does admit
to drunk texting JLo I drop dead JLo oh
no soy bounce-back last December
JLo when Drake shot a prom themed music
video for the song get it together you
can hear J Lo's voice right here
[Music]
but on the final track JLo has been
replaced by artist Georgia Smith leading
some to believe Drake's throwing some
major shade Drake
okay I'm no no not with Drake she's with
a ride yes that's right that's j-rod I
still can't believe we're combining
names but anyway they are the newest are
a couple but are they too cute us cuz
take a look at the weekend planting a
big kiss on his gal Selena Gomez and
even cuter he took her to the aquarium
in Toronto this weekend I like it I mean
he's from Canada I'm from Canada I'm a
little biased Joycelyn his home country
[Music]